Speaker 1: Hey, everybody. Producer Pat here,
bringing you some holiday cheer on this Christmas
Eve. Let's get back into the news story, starting
with this one about the 2024 presidential race.
A new poll finds that a majority of Americans
don't want to see Donald Trump run for president
again. But also a majority of Americans. They
don't want to see Joe Biden run for president
again, either. The poll comes to us from Echelon
Insights, and the results are that 55 percent of
respondents don't want to see Donald Trump seek
the presidency again in 2024. And that's great
news, right? But also statistically just as many
54 percent of respondents they say that they don't
want to see Joe Biden run again as well. Now on
the approval side, when you flip the question
and ask, Do you want Trump to one run? Do you want
Biden to run? There does seem to be more support
for Trump running than Biden. 39 percent give
Trump the go ahead, whereas only 34 percent say
the same thing about Biden. So the question is
three years out from the next presidential race.
Is this cause for concern for Democrats? I think
part of this is that Americans are saying they
want to see new faces, you know, if Trump runs
again. This will be his third attempt. He's been
nonstop in the political atmosphere ever since
2015. Biden, he's been in the Senate forever,
and then he was vice president. He ran a bunch
of different presidential campaigns. And then,
of course, now he is the president. So, you know,
it's just time to see some new people here. We're
sort of sick of these guys and we don't want to
see an exact repeat of the 2020 election, after
all. And part of this also is the fact that they
are quite up there in age, right? If Trump gets
elected in 2024, he's going to be seventy eight by
the time he's elected and 82 by the time he leaves
office. And if Joe Biden gets reelected, he's
going to be 82 at the start of his second term.
And 86 by the time that he's out of office.
And we know that of course, people now are
living longer lives these days, and you can have
elderly people who are capable of doing the job.
But some may say 80s, that's kind of pushing
it. Maybe we need some younger blood in there,
but I think this really comes down to at the end
of the day. The most important factor in all of
this is that the hardcore Trump people who make up
somewhere between 35 to 40 percent, unfortunately
of the country, they want him no matter
what, right? They don't care about Ted Cruz,
they don't care about Nikki Haley. You know, maybe
Ron DeSantis is OK, but only as a back up option
if Trump doesn't want to run. And so that's, I
think, why we're seeing the numbers show that
39 percent of people say they do want Trump to
run. Those are the hardcore Trump supporters,
whereas there's people who support
Joe Biden, but they don't have the
same sort of cult of personality view of
him, right? Biden doesn't have this sort of
appeal that Trump does among his base of
supporters. Biden's approval rating right
now is in the low to mid 40s, which is not great.
It's also not terrible. But the number who wants
to see him run again is again 34 percent, which
is substantially lower than what his approval
numbers at. So that suggests to me that there's
a good amount of people who are saying, Yeah,
I like what Biden is doing, but he's replaceable,
right? Like if you give us Kamala Harris,
if you give us Pete Buttigieg or Elizabeth Warren
or whoever else we'll like them to, because at the
end of the day, it's more about the cause than the
person. And then also in addition, you don't have
to worry about the age factor. You don't have to
worry about age or fitness or anything like that.
So that's my take away. The Trump people are
wrapped up in the cult of Trump, and the Biden
people don't care about Biden specifically. They
just want to move the causes forward. And I think
there's a real question whether Biden will run
again, mainly because of the age factor. I think
that if he chooses not to run again, obviously
there will be a primary in the Democratic field.
There's a possibility that Kamala Harris being
the vice president, she caught, she gets that
coronation treatment that Hillary Clinton got
back in 2016. Hopefully that doesn't happen,
and hopefully we get some progressive challenges
in there to make it not so easy to fight for her.
But ultimately, if Biden chooses to run again,
he'll get the nomination. And I think Trump is
definitely running again. Also, I mean, he's
dropping all these hints as to how he's going to
launch another campaign. I know some people
like Michael Cohen, for example, he's saying in
including on the show, he said, I don't think that
Trump is going to run again because he's terrified
of losing for a second time. He doesn't want to be
seen as a two time loser. And the excuse of voter
fraud, if he does lose, isn't going to work again.
But I just don't buy that like it. First of all,
I think that if Trump does run again, he's going
to have a substantial chance at winning. I think
he's actually going to get better odds of winning
than he did in 2016 or 2020. And if he does lose,
then he'll just tell his voters, Yeah, it was
voter fraud, and they're already primed to believe
the voter fraud stuff. They'll just say, like, OK,
well, they got us again, those Democrats rigging
their elections. So, you know, I don't think Trump
is really worried about anything there. It's sort
of a heads. I win tails. You lose sort of scenario
where either he wins the presidency or he just
says once again that he got cheated. So the bottom
line is most Americans don't want to see Trump run
again. Most Americans don't want to see Biden run
again. And yet there's still a halfway decent shot
that we see yet another Trump Biden match up a.
A repeat of the last election cycle in twenty.